the first rough plot of the Mando BR set
appeared in a 1978 paper by the
mathematicians Robert Brooks and J Peter
matelski soon after Ben wall mandoob BR
a researcher at IBM who had access to
more computing power also discovered the
set this led to further
Explorations these early computer
Graphics were crude but the patterns
revealed the presence of something far
more complex even with like fuzzy like
poorly made pictures in the in the 880s
they were able to really glean a lot of
interesting insight into what's going on
mandal BR went on to popularized as Now
aonomus set to the world and became
known as the father of fractals today
mathematicians can use computers to
explore the Mando BR set in far greater
detail as soon as you have images just
opens up this whole world people didn't
know
[Music]
about